social media companies they have to show
America their algorithms Nikki Haley and
I consider myself friendly with Nikki
Haley she's had dinner at my house I she
is a fine a fine lady I obviously do not
agree with her on everything uh she said
something that was that was pretty scary
a couple days ago on the ruthless
podcast uh she went on there uh and she
you'll see she's now I think we're
showing you a Fox news clip if I'm not
mistaken right it's from Fox News she
followed up on the notion that she
brought up on the ruthless podcast about
how she wants to require every person on
social media to be verified by ID
meaning no Anonymous accounts on social
media uh here she is when I get into
office the first thing we have to do
social media accounts social media
companies they have to show America
their algorithms let us see why they're
pushing what they're pushing the second
thing is every person on social media
should be verified by their name that's
first of all it's a national security
threat when you do that all of a sudden
people have to stand by what they say
and it gets rid of the Russian Bots the
Iranian Bots and the Chinese Bots and
then you're going to get some civility
when people know their name is next to
what they say accountability and they
know their pastor and their family memb
is going to see it it's going to help
our kids and it's going to help our
country okay so there there's a couple
things here first off the the first
concept that she said which is that I
would go into the social media companies
and make them show their algorithms
we've discussed this before it is
unclear if the social media companies
know what's going on in their algorithms
all together as Elon Musk literally told
me personally the the Twitter code is a
fractal rub Goldberg machine remember
ruub Goldberg machine the beginning of
PeeWee Herman's Big Adventure the ball
that drops into the thing and it fills
up the water and it knocks Down The
Dominoes and everything else and a
fractal version of that meaning it is so
layered it is so confused it's been
written 20 years ago by many people who
are no longer at the company and by the
way this goes for Google this goes for
Facebook this goes for YouTube and
everywhere else that the idea that the
that government agents could walk in in
to Google or Twitter or elsewhere and be
like show us the algorithm like some
middle management pathetic government
employee with a hard hat could I want to
see the algorithm and I'm going to
figure it out like the very notion of
that is is sort of completely ridiculous
the the concept like intellectually
would it be nice if we knew what the
algorithms were saying and which way
they were pushing you if you happen to
watch a Reuben report video and I say
something that might let's say push you
this way a little bit is the YouTube
algorithm trying to counter that with a
whole bunch of other things because they
don't want you to think things that I
think so the concept in Theory actually
makes some sense that we should know
about the algorithms uh but in terms of
what the government can do and how the
government might use that against you
ultimately I think you see my point now
on the on the more sort of uh let's say
scary side of this thing uh she's saying
that Anonymous accounts online are a
national security threat and she's
talking about these Russian and Iranian
Bots and all that first off there's
there's two different things happening
here on one hand the ability for people
to be anonymous online look I find it to
be a massive headache all the time right
because the people that write the worst
things to me all day long all day long
and I assure you in the last month it's
been worse than ever they're always
Anonymous that's like that's how it is
and you have no idea which ones of them
are Bots and and now with AI they can
the Bots can be really clever and really
come across like their people but the
idea that people should be allowed to be
anonymous you know the Federalist Papers
were written by Anonymous founders of
this country
uh because they did not want to get in
trouble with the King over in Britain
you know so there is obviously a reason
that people should be able to have
anonymity as annoying as it is now if
she wanted to figure out a way to
encourage let's say the big tech
companies to go after the Bots yes the
Bots are a huge problem because what's
happening is we're seeing people be
swarmed so that you cannot gauge what's
true so if you were to just say
something something completely um
completely ambivalent right water is wet
you will get a jillion bots in your
account you think you're a racist
because you think water's wet what about
vapor
and and they look like real people and
it can actually
disregulated all that and we know
obviously a huge amount is coming out of
Russia and China and Iran and everywhere
else but the idea that you would take
away anonymity altogether is
nuts